il
[Musique]
bonjour pour ce nouveau numéro de v y
paie vers yvelinoise personne je reçois
aujourd'hui l'abbé grosjean bien vu sur
ce plateau rouge bonjour vous êtes ce
prêtre du diocèse de versailles membres
de sa commission éthique et politique
mais aussi curé de la paroisse de
montigny et de voisins le bretonneux
on vous présente comme un curé 2.0 déjà
pour vous situer un petit peu vous êtes
amateur de blogs très présent sur les
réseaux sociaux sur twitter notamment
ces images qui vous convient que ray 2.0
a cure et moderne
non d'abord ce qui me convient c'est
surtout de curé de paroisse parce que
oui et c'est très important justement de
garder les pieds enracinés ancré sur le
terrain ça pour un prêtre c'est
essentiel là où je trouve ma joie de
prêtres c'est vraiment auprès de mes
paroissiens sur le terrain et c'est
important justement que ces réseaux
sociaux qui permettent c'est vrai de
s'adresser à des personnes qui viennent
pas forcément l'église et de parler au
delà des frontières de la paroisse en
même temps de nous des racines pas il
faut rester dans le réel
pas simplement dans le virtuel et mon
réel mon quotidien c'est ma paroisse
c'est les clochers de montigny voisins
et c'est là où je trouve ma joie voulait
rester au contact et pas uniquement
derrière un écran d'ordinateur c'est
exactement ça c'est important d'ailleurs
que les que les rencontres qui peuvent
se faire les contacts se faire par le le
numérique donne lieu ensuite à des
rencontres en vrai c'est toujours mieux
de rencontrer en vrai alors pour un
prêtre c'est d'autant plus important
parce que je crois beaucoup à la grâce
de la rencontre c'est là où on peut
vraiment échanger connaître nez et vous
servir ceux qui nous ont confié c'est
pour cette raison vous avez organisé sur
cette paroisse de montigné
voisins-le-bretonneux plusieurs
événements on va revenir dans un instant
au-delà de ça au delà de cette paroisse
vous avez acquis tout de même ces
dernières années une certaine notoriété
au niveau national de par vos prises de
position
c'est important pour vous aussi de
porter la voix de l'église dans tout cas
de votre vision et de vos valeurs
au-delà de cette paroisse c'est une
mission que l'évêque m'a confié de
pouvoir effectivement rendre l'église
présente dans le débat public
je crois que c'est avaient partie du
service que l'église peut rendre à la
société d'être une voix libre
une voix libre qui éveille les
consciences qui ne cherche pas à imposer
quoi que ce soit mais qui simplement
éveil voir alerte les consciences 30 il
lui semble que sur tel ou tel point la
dignité des personnes humaines et
particulièrement déplu
gilles est en jeu le pape françois bodin
un bel exemple et nos évêques à sa suite
et c'est justement d'être un peu comme
des des repères d'offrir en tout cas la
société des repères un peu stable qui
permette à chacun ensuite d'éclairer son
discernement et donc vous avez pris
position notamment au moment du mariage
pour tous vous étiez opposé à ce mariage
pour tous aujourd'hui l'évolution fait
que on parle de la pma notamment dans
l'actualité vous prenez position aussi
vous continuer ce combat entre
guillemets en fait je ne fais que
relayer la parole de notre évêque
monseigneur aumôniers on l'avait déjà
dit à quelques années effectivement la
question de la filiation allait
forcément être au coeur des débats
si ce match pour tout se passe et c'est
le cas aujourd'hui avec la progression
médicalement assistée ouverte aux femmes
seules ou couples de femmes
et en fait derrière c'est toujours la
même question c'est comment tout en
respectant infiniment les personnes
lorsqu'elle vivait en reconnaissant même
ce qu'il ya de beau dans ce que chacun
peut vivre comment on protège les
repères fondamentaux sur lesquels notre
société se construit la question de la
paternité
la question de la filiation ses repères
anthropologique qui sont fondamentaux
pour la société il faut les protéger il
faut les garder il faut les préserver
accepter aussi que le désir soit pas
tout puissant je comprends et j'entends
le désir des uns des autres et en même
temps voyez ces ses limites de notre
condition humaine
il me semble aussi qu'elles sont à à
préserver parce qu'elles sont elles sont
précieuses
parce qu'elle nous rend du coup elles
font qu'on a besoin les uns des autres
et nous rendre complémentaires les uns
des autres et puis je crois aussi que
dans ce projet de loi il y avait aussi
de la question de la recherche médicale
et cette dérégulation de la recherche
médicale
là aussi nous pose des graves questions
de éthique de conscience sur lesquels
nous alertons dont vous utilisez des
outils plutôt modernes comme les blogs
comme les réseaux sociaux pour véhiculer
les valeurs traditionnelles en tout cas
fondamental de
10 nous parlons à tous l'église encore
une fois n'impose rien elle propose elle
parle elle s'adresse à la liberté des
uns et des autres et elle elle elle
cherche à éveiller les consciences avec
les moyens qui lui sont offertes par
l'époque disait tout à l'heure vous êtes
donc spécialisée aussi sur ces questions
éthiques et bioéthiques comment vous
agissez au quotidien au delà de votre
paroisse de par ses missions qui nous
ont été confiées il s'agit de deux
d'échangés je crois surtout moi
justement je vous le disais à la grâce
de la rencontre est loin des des comment
dire des slogans ou des des petites
phrases qui sont parfois un peu
désespérante justement sur les réseaux
sociaux on sent qu'il ya une difficulté
aujourd'hui à établir un vrai dialogue
respectueux des personnes où l'on peut
vraiment cherché à comprendre la logique
de l'autre à comprendre la cohérence
même si on n'est pas d'accord
eh bien je crois que c'est beaucoup dans
la rencontre personnelle qu'on peut
partager ses arguments qu'on peut
expliquer qu'on peut partager les
inquiétudes qu'on peut avoir mais aussi
encourager et c'est ce qu'on fait en
particulier en rencontrant les élus il
s'agit à la fois d'encourager et
d'alerté c'est ce qui peut motiver aussi
votre engagement très jeune dans cette
dans cette voie là il
j'aime l'idée de chercher à convaincre
de la beauté et de la justesse de la
sagesse de l'église j'aime partager ce
qui fait ma foi ce qui fait mon
espérance et j'aime débattre entre est
en débat toujours avec encore une fois
un respect profond des personnes s'est
jamais un combat contre les personnes
c'est toujours un débat d'idées mais
parce que je crois que c'est encore
quelque chose de très beau à vivre
ensemble c'est de rechercher ensemble la
vérité c'est pas ma vérité
j'essaye de chercher ce qui est vrai ce
qui est bon ce qui est juste pour notre
société
le bien commun l'église se veut au
service non pas de ses propres intérêts
mais du bien commun du bien de tous et
je trouve ça passionnant dit travailler
avec tous les hommes et les femmes de
bonne volonté qu'ils soient croyants ou
non
on est là pour servir ensemble ce bien
commun ça veut dire que votre vision
peut évoluer aussi avait forcément quand
vous parler avec quelqu'un ce qu'il vous
dit vous enrichit et encore une fois ça
veut dire qu'on est d'accord sur tout
mais chercher à comprendre les autres
chercher à comprendre leur cohérence
chercher à avoir ce qu'il ya de beau
aussi dans leur vie est toujours
infiniment précieux et nous fait grandir
même si je crois aussi qu'il ya des
repères profondément stable kiki qui
sont au contraire infiniment précieux a
gardé dans un monde qui bouge en
permanence dans un monde qui où les
modes de l'opinion évolue très vite et
bien
c'est il me semble un grand service que
l'église nous rend de nous montrer ce
qui est structurant de nous montrer ce
qui doit ce qui est toujours vrai et de
montrer ce qui est stable skis sur
lesquels sud du coup on peut s'appuyer
parce que c'est pas une mode parce que
c'est pas quelque chose qui va changer
ce qui est vrai et ce qui est juste qui
est bon pour l'homme demeure et il n'y a
pas de raison que ça ça change au fond
et comment ça se traduit au quotidien
justement vous parlez de du terrain de
ces rencontres les paroissiens qui
viennent vous voir ou ceux qui ne sont
pas croyants et qui viennent vous voir
aussi qu'elles sont un petit peu les
préoccupations en ce moment qu'ils
peuvent aborder avec vous les
inquiétudes je crois que c'est assez
paradoxal à la fois on voit bien qu'il
ya une diminution très claire de la
pratique religieuse et en même temps il
ya une soif spirituelle qui s'exprime
toujours autant et je trouve ça
impressionnant de voir que justement le
beaucoup se rendent compte que
ce monde ne suffit pas à leur donner une
espérance qui ne déçoit pas certes on
peut avoir un confort de vie on peut
avoir consommé beaucoup produire
beaucoup etc mais il y a dans le coeur
de l'homme
une soif un désir d'absolu une soif
spirituelle à laquelle à laquelle on
cherche des réponses et il me semble que
c'est c'est à cela que nous devons nous
chrétiens répondre parce que nous sommes
porteurs d'une bonne nouvelle qui est
pas réservé à quelques-uns l'église
c'est pas un club fermé
c'est vraiment un oasis moi j'aime bien
dire que la parole pour moi ça doit être
un oasis au coeur de la ville là où on
vient étancher sa soif là on revient
s'abreuver là on vient chercher de quoi
se ressourcer pour ensuite continuer sa
vie avancé sur son chemin qui est
parfois aride qui parfois difficile et
voilà dans une société qui peut parfois
ressembler un désert spirituel la parole
c'est comme un oasis infiniment précieux
ouvert à tous est ouvert à tous
justement avec les manifestations les
organisations que vous allez faire
notamment ce week end les 12 et 13
octobre
si on en parle un petit peu plus il y
aura une bénédiction des animaux par
exemple là aussi c'est un peu atypique
en fait on a voulu faire comme une sorte
de week-end portes ouvertes
vous savez que dans l'église le pape
françois a voulu que ce mois d'octobre
soit un mois missionnaire est donc dans
le diocèse de versailles dans les
yvelines
ça se traduit par un week-end en
particulier missionnaire ce 12 13
octobre ou dans toutes les paroles vont
avoir lieu
des initiatives qui permettent à chacun
de découvrir ou de redécouvrir sa
paroisse c'est vraiment l'occasion
vraiment de s'adresser à tous même ceux
qui n'ont pas l'habitude de venir à la
parole avec pour montigny voisin trois
événement un peu particulier originaux
le premier c'est effectivement une
bénédiction des animaux bénir ça veut
dire dire du bien et il s'agit en fait
de reconnaître que les animaux nos
animaux de compagnie et bien sont un don
de dieu c'est dieu qui les a créées qui
les a voulus et c'est vrai qu'il nous
rende service
alors je parle pas simplement des ddd
des chiens aveugles ou des chiens
policiers qui rendent un vrai service
mais aussi tous ceux qui égaye nos vies
de famille et puis ceux qui bafouent
parfois aussi permettre de rompre la
solitude
chez beaucoup d'entre nous et donc on va
on en a eu envie de rendre grâce de dire
merci pour ces animaux de reconnaître
qu'ils sont un bond de dieu et de les
bénir en ce sens bien sûr c'est
l'occasion aussi d'accueillir leurs
maîtres pour qui on priera aussi donc ce
samedi matin à 11 heures à vos seins
bretonneux devant l'église
et puis on a aussi ce samedi soir à 19h
une guinguette paroissiale petite fête
de village en quelque sorte sur le
parvis de l'église saint martin à
montigny-le-bretonneux
là c'est offrir un temps de convivialité
parce que je crois que c'est aussi ce
que ça que les gens recherchent que
l'église soit pas simplement un lieu de
prière mais aussi un lieu de vie
fraternelle
c'est infiniment précieux dans nos
villes d'avoir des lieux de gratuité des
lieux de fraternité des lieux de
convivialité où l'on découvre que la
parole c'est aussi une communauté une
famille où chacun à sa place donc une
guinguette part au ciel avec de la
musique avec des jeux avec de quoi se
restaurer puis l'occasion effectivement
d'en profiter pour rentrer dans l'église
allait prier déposer de ses intentions
de prière déposer un cierge et puis
enfin troisième événement c'est le
dimanche 13 octobre à 15 heures à
l'église saint pierre dulac on va dire
le chapelet puisque c'est l'anniversaire
des apparitions de notre dame de fatima
et donc on priera particulièrement pour
les personnes malades voilà alors on a
parlé un petit peu de ces différents
événements arrivent à la fin de cette
émission peut être aussi nous dire
qu'elles sont ou si vous avez des des
ambitions motivation personnelle vous
êtes là pour les six prochaines années
encore cinq ans sur la paroisse de
l'endettement est nommé curé pour six
ans est le grand projet ce serait
effectivement la construction d'une
nouvelle église
vous savez quel ce projet qui depuis est
enfin qui mûrit depuis des années qui a
été lancée par son prédécesseur et qui
que je vais être amené à mettre en
oeuvre avec toute une équipe bien sûr de
paroissiens la construction d'une
nouvelle église de 800 places une grande
église sur le terrain de la remise sur
0,2 mixera une église pour voisins et
montigny puisqu'on a des très belles
petites églises mais qui sont trop
petites pour rassembler tous les
chrétiens en particulier le dimanche aux
grandes fêtes et donc ça va être un
projet dans les trois ans qui viennent
avec je l'espère une vertu en 2022 ça
sera un projet qui va marquer à la fois
la parole mais aussi la ville bien sûr
merci beaucoup avait grosjean d'avoir
participé à ce numéro de v y paie on se
retrouve très bientôt sur télé 78
[Musique]